Our presses are connected since 1994,...
...so since more than 25 years.
But today, we are receiving up to 100,000 sets of data per press and per day.
And the key is to evaluate and interpret the data...
...and take action from these findings,...
...which enables us to offer tailor-made solutions and services...
...fitting your individual production conditions.
But before we talk about a few of these unique solutions,...
...let's experience what features our Rapida 145...
...are minimizing maintenance time.
Minimizing maintenance time is a very good keyword...
...because this is the focal point of our latest development...
...for the new large format generation.
We are eliminating and centralizing lubrication points.
And for example, we have developed long-life gripper shafts.
I can show you here directly in the machine.
So all the gripper shafts on impression cylinder and transfer drums,...
...there is no lubrication needed...
...because there are no greasing points anymore.
So this is one of the first developments we have realized...
...to reduce greasing points and minimize maintenance...
...in terms of greasing the machine.
Another advantage: there are no splashes of grease...
...on printed sheets after over greasing...
...or you also have to spend less time for the whole maintenance cycle per week,...
...so our progressive metering technology with automatic grease supply.